on fait le détail le déroulement de
cette journée le déroulement de cette
vague terroriste aux etats unis les
dernières images montées commenté
thierry kurt et
cercle et à gauche le deuxième avion
détourné le boeing kamikazes visent et
s'écrase sur la tour encore intacte
l'avion de ligne n'a pas dévié d'un
mètre ils frappent la tour en son milieu
le world trade center se trouve au sud
de manhattan
à deux pas de wall street dans le
quartier des affaires 18 minutes avant
un premier avion de ligne détourné lui
aussi s'est crashé sur la première des
deux tours jumelles l'opération a été
parfaitement minute et quarante minutes
plus tard washington
un troisième avion vient s'écraser sur
le bâtiment le plus stratégie des états
unis d'amérique le pentagone le siège du
commandement militaire
puis on apprend qu'un quatrième avion un
747 également détourné s'est écrasé près
de pittsburgh
les quatre appareils provenaient de
trois villes différentes
il transportait 2 166 personnes à new
york
les deux avions transformé en missile
ont percuté les deux tours au moment de
l'arrivée au bureau des 50000 personnes
qui travaillent au world trade center
vers 9h ce matin des dizaines d'employés
font des signes désespérés
d'autres choisissent de sauter par les
fenêtres les deux bâtiments jumeaux
mesure 410 mètres de haut
mais les deux tours véritable monument
dédié à l'économie américaine ne vont
pas résisté bien longtemps
la première se brise par le milieu
bascule et c'est faux la deuxième
implose et s'écroule
chacun des deux bâtiments pèse près de
300 mille tonnes située au bord d'une
rivière nos côtés mais à dossier au
quartier des affaires de wall street
de l'autre le maire de new york parle
d'un homme né froid yable bilan sans
avancer le moindre chic l'aef à
l'aviation civile américaine décide de
fermer tous les aéroports des états unis
plusieurs avions civils autorisés à
voler les trains doivent rester en gare
les frontière avec le mexique sont
fermées
l'amérique est paralysé